>> Sean: WE ARE NINE WEEKS
AWAY FROM THE MIDTERM RACES AND
KEY SENATE MATCHUPS ARE
BEGINNING TO TAKE SHAPE.
ROB LUKENS NOR ON THE RISE.
THAT INCLUDES IN GEORGIA,
HERSCHEL WALKER, THIS RACE IS
NECK AND NECK.
THE LAST TWO POOLS HAVE HERSCHEL
UP OVER RAPHAEL WARNOCK AND THE
SENATE MAY BE DECIDED BY THE
STATE OF GEORGIA.
INCUMBENT SENATOR RAPHAEL
WARNOCK HAS AGREED TO FINALLY
DEBATE HERSCHEL WALKER.
AN OFFER IN SAVANNAH THAT WAS
MADE.
THAT WILL HAPPEN IN OCTOBER.
HERE'S THE LATEST AD FROM THE
WALKER CAMPAIGN LAYING OUT JUST
WHAT IS AT STAKE IN THE GREAT
STATE OF GEORGIA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ABSOLUTELY AGREE AS RACIST.
IT'S A REDUX OF JIM CROW.
IN A SUIT AND TIE.
>> AMERICA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> YOU AIN'T BLACK.
>> AMERICA HAS A PRE-EXISTING
CONDITION CALLED RACISM.
>> SENATOR WARNOCK BELIEVES
AMERICA IS A BAD COUNTRY FULL OF
RACIST PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE WE ARE A GREAT COUNTRY
FULL OF GENEROUS PEOPLE.
WARNOCK WANTS TO DIVIDE US.
I WANT TO BRING US TOGETHER.
I'M HERSCHEL WALKER.
I APPROVE THIS MESSAGE.
>> Sean: I GUESS THE POLLS ARE
BRINGING OUT THE SENATE
CANDIDATES FOR THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE IT PENNSYLVANIA TONIGHT,
JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOW AGREED TO
DEBATE DR. MEHMET OZ.
WILL THE PHONY SPOILED SOCIALIST
TRUST FUND BRAT IN A
HOODIE, IS HE GOING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH?
FROM BOTH STATES, DEBATES NEED
TO TAKE PLACE BEFORE A SINGLE
VOTE IS EVEN CAST.
THAT'S ONLY FAIR FOR VOTERS.
HERE NOW IS GEORGIA SENATE
CANDIDATE HERSCHEL ROCKER.
BEFORE I GET TO ONE CHANGE IN
THE DYNAMICS, RAPHAEL WARNOCK
SUPPORTS COURT PACKING, AND INTO
CASH BAIL.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE YOUTH
CAMP KID ABUSE SCANDAL.
DIDN'T WANT THE POLICE TO
INTERVIEW THE PEOPLE INVOLVED.
HE HAS PRAISED LOUIS FARRAKHAN,
REVEREND JEREMIAH RIGHT, HE'S
COMPARED THE POLICE TO THUGS AND
GANGSTERS.
HE WANTS A GRID OF FOSSIL FUELS.
HE WANTS CRT IN OUR SCHOOLS.
HE IS SAID THAT THE OPIOID
CRISIS IS ONLY AN ISSUE BECAUSE
IT'S IMPACTING PEOPLE THAT ARE
WHITE AND SUBURBAN.
THE GUY ALSO BY THE WAY HAS A
PROBLEM NEGLECTING HIS CHILDREN
AND FAILING TO PAY CHILD CARE
EXPENSES.
HIS EX-WIFE CLAIMED HE RAN OVER
HER IN A DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
I CAN KEEP GOING ON.
HOW IS THIS RACE EVEN CLOSE?
THE MONITORING OF MEDIA IN
GEORGIA SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVE AGAINST YOU BUT NOW
YOUR MESSAGE SEEMS TO BE
PENETRATING WITH RECENT POLLS.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THE REASON WHY, SEAN, IS I AM
GETTING OUT AND MEETING THE
PEOPLE.
I AM TALKING TO THE PEOPLE AND
THE PEOPLE ARE SPEAKING.
THEY HAVE SPENT OVER $50 MILLION
AGAINST ME.
BUT THE RACE STILL TIGHT.
I'M UP BY 1.
THE REASON WHY IS PEOPLE WANT A
CHANGE IN WASHINGTON.
SENATOR WARNOCK IS A CUT FROM
THE CLOTH FOR JOE BIDEN AND WHAT
I MEAN BY THAT IS HE BELIEVES IN
HIGHER TAXES, HE BELIEVE IN OPEN
WATERS.
HE VOTED TO PUT MEN IN WOMEN'S
SPORTS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT GEORGIA PEOPLE
WANT.
THEY WANT SOMEONE WHO CAN TRUST
WHERE THEY CAN TRUST HERSCHEL
WALKER.
NO MATTER WHAT, HE'S NOT GOING
TO TALK ANYTHING, THE MEDIA'S
NOT GOING TO SAY ANYTHING
POSITIVE ABOUT ME I'VE DONE A
LOT OF POSITIVE THINGS.
HE'S DONE A LOT OF NEGATIVE
THINGS.
LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT HIS RECORD AS A
SENATOR.
AS A SENATOR, HE HASN'T DONE A
GOOD JOB AND ITS TIMERS WOULD
ALSO TAKE THAT SEAT FIGHTING FOR
THE PEOPLE.
THAT SEAT BELONGS TO THE PEOPLE
GEORGIA.
>> Sean: WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
THE TIME DOES RAPHAEL WARNOCK
VOTE WITH CHUCK SCHUMER AND WITH
JOE BIDEN?
>> IT IS 96% OF THE TIME.
96% OF THE TIME.
HE DON'T EVEN WANT TO CAMPAIGN
WITH JOE BIDEN NOW.
HE'S TRYING TO DISTANCE HIMSELF
FROM IT.
BUT HE CAN'T.
HE CAN'T DISTANCE HIMSELF.
BECAUSE HE'S JUST, LIKE I SAY
COME HE'S CUT FROM THE SAME
CLOTH AS JOE BIDEN.
I CALL HIM A WOLF IN SHEEP'S
CLOTHING.
HE PRETENDS HE TRIES TO HELP YOU
BUT ALL THE TIME HE'S CONTINUING
TO HURT YOU.
YOU'VE SEEN THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE HURTING FROM THE ECONOMY.
PEOPLE HERE ARE HURTING FROM THE
CRIME.
BUT YET HE'S PROFITED WHILE HE
HAS BEEN IN OFFICE.
IF ANYONE IS GOING TO HURT US.
>> Sean: PEOPLE.
SPEAK OF THE PEOPLE WHO PUT YOU
IN OFFICE.
>> Sean: HE DOUBLED HIS
INCOME.
DOUBLE THE INCOME AS A
POLITICIAN.
>> HE'S ONLY BEEN IN WASHINGTON
FOR A LITTLE BIT.
NOW HIS INCOME HAS GONE UP.
NOW YOU SAY.
HE WANTS TO DEBATE ME.
HE STILL HAVE A COUPLE THINGS.
HE SAYS IF YOU DO THIS, IF YOU
DO THAT.
WHY WON'T HE JUST SHOW UP ON
OCTOBER 14 FOR A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE DEBATE?
IT'S ABOUT THE PEOPLE.
TO THE PEOPLE CAN SEE THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN THE TWO OF US.
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
RAISE MONEY.
>> Sean: I WANT TO KNOW --
SINGLE VOTE IS CAST WITH EARLY
VOTING.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THE REASON
WHY.
IT'S LIKE A GAME FOR THEM.
THEY'VE BEEN RAISING MONEY.
THAT'S MY TELL PEOPLE TO GO TO
TeamHerschel.com AND LET'S
RAISE THIS MONEY SO WE CAN GET
INTO A DEBATE BECAUSE ALL THEY
WANT TO DO IS PUT NEGATIVE ADS
OUT THERE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T WIN
ON THE ISSUES.
THEY CAN'T WIN ON THE ISSUES AND
NOW THEY SEE THAT THE POLLS ARE
CHANGING, THEY ARE BEING TOLD BY
THEIR PEOPLE, YOU'VE GOT TO
DEBATE.
YOU'VE GOT TO DEBATE.
I AM TELLING HIM TO PUT HIS BIG
MAN PANTS ON, SHOW UP IN
SAVANNAH, GEORGIA, OCTOBER 14.
THAT'S DEBATE.
PEOPLE CAN VIEW THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US.
>> Sean: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS
WITH THESE LATE DEBATES, A LOT
OF PEOPLE WILL HAVE VOTED BY
THEN.
THAT TO ME IS A PROBLEM.
I THINK DEBATES SHOULD TAKE
PLACE BEFORE A SINGLE VOTE IS
CAST.
BUT I WILL BE WATCHING.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO IT.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR RECENT
POLLING SURGING.
THIS COULD BE